when I was a resident I had a viral
moment of Fame it was like check out
this hot doctor and his husband no that
was the name of the article yeah wow
that is the time where a lot of people
were going viral for their looks there
was a Target the weather person so once
he wrote it trending number one on
BuzzFeed that next week Ellen DeGeneres
is calling Steve Harvey's call
everyone's arguing to have you on their
show because you're like the IT thing
and then I said you know what I'll do
Ellen Degeneres Show day before they
cancel on me and they say hey Hillary
Clinton is announcing her run for
presidency and the other guests are
Jimmy Kimmel and pink we're now bumping
them we're bumping you so I'm like no
problem I'll call Steve Harvey back or
all these other shows and do them I
called and they're like Oh no you're
last week's news we don't care about you
anymore no your old news now so I said
cool I'll start a YouTube channel all
from the BuzzFeed article that was
written that prompted it yep
[Music]